στο φιλόδοξο σχέδιον και που έχει γίνιποτέ για των καρκίνο συν ευρωπαρική ένωση με μια
χρηματοδότησιάνοντων τεσσάρωτης εκατομιλίων ευρώ που ίδη έχει πιφέρει πολλές αλλαγές και εχειβάλειτες βάσεις για να
υπάρχει μια διαφορετική αντιμετώπιση διότι αυτό που είναι το στίχημα είναι ότι όλη ασθενίς ανεξαρτίτως
σε πια χώραζούν πρέχουν να έχουν το ίδιο δικαίωμα σε πρόσβασης σε θεραπείες και φάρμακα
και εποιότητα ζωής και αυτό είναι ο στόχος αυτού του σχέδίου και ίδη βλέπουμε ότι
άρχισε και προσφέρει αυτό που αναμένουν οι ευρωπαίοι πολίτες και στην κύπρο αντωτη και μα
στε λήθι ναμαάχηπουδόθηκε το χρόνια και ήτα σε σαλκάμια δικία η οποία υπήρχε το δικαίο
μα στη λήθειταν ένα ίτοημα που υπήρχε από τους καρκοινοπαηθείς εδώ και χρόνιας στην ευρώποια
λλά εμείς το αναδείξαμε πλέος σε ευρωπαϊκό επίπεδο και όταν ανάλαβαμε η νομίζωι ήταν έξι
εφτά κρατη μέλι που το είχαν ριθμίσει των είναι στα δεκατρία έχουμε οκόμμαται καλεφτά πότε
έκομη δεν συγνομικόματι κατέσερο πότε δεν είμαστε ικανοποιημένοι αλλά προχωρά και πίσως μέσω στους επόμενους
μήνες να έχει προχωρήσει πριν ολοκληρωθεί η θτια υπάτεα για τό όταν διαγνωστηκάτεσης εσείς πως
το αντιμετώπισα και στανι σκέψεις που περνοόπως όλοι άλλη ασθενίς πουοι άνθρωποί όχι ασθενίσω όπως
όοι λλι άνθρωποι που έρχουνται αντιμέτωπε με μιαδιάγνωση με τη λέξη καρκίνους φόβο θα βεβαιότητα
όπως πάρα πολλές γυναίκες είχαμια εργαζόμενοι σχετικά νεαρί μητέρα διοπαιδιών όλοι οι οι ένιαθα δεις
τα παιδιάς